uh the reason that i was focusing on if
you've been hit or been assaulted is
because you know people are slapping
people these days i don't know if you
know i don't know if you guys know where
i'm going
so obviously what's going on in the news
these days
is
what's happened at the oscars everyone's
talking about it but the difference is
here in the sauce cast we're getting
females opinions on this too there's a
lot of guys talking about this
uh you know will smith he's a sip is
this if i was chris rock i would have
hit him
so i wanna you know nobody needs an
intro as to what happened we've all seen
it at this point
but i want to just set the table get
some ladies perspectives like what is
jada thinking during all this what does
willow smith think in all this so we all
know what happened you know i'm a huge
fan of cursed rock i was a huge fan i
still am a huge fan of will smith yeah
but i feel like he's been emasculated
lately so from a female ladies and
gentlemen well i don't know if you're
here i know are you can we call you
later what is a woman a gender
female's perspective what happened put
yourself in jada's shoes put yourself in
your own shoes what happened josh
so basically i feel like um well
well obviously it was funny it was very
funny that he actually walked up there
and he slapped him i'm not gonna lie
that was kind of funny
um it looks like he was like out of a
[ __ ] movie when he went up there he
slapped him but in the same breath i
feel like he um like he protected his
wife you know like
you don't know the conversations that go
on in their marriage so it was an
emotional reaction obviously it was
emotional
um
you can see will he left if you look at
the video you can see he will he laughed
at it at first
he laughed at it but i think once it
registered in his mind he was just like
is that [ __ ] really funny i don't think
it's really funny
did that turn you on to see
your man run up and slap someone what
are your thoughts
well assuming that it happened like for
real and it wasn't just trying to get
attention to the oscars because no one's
really watching the oscars anymore let's
be honest but we'll assume it's real
okay um i personally wouldn't he's a
comedian i wouldn't have been offended
by the joke and if we want to be women
empowerment i think if a comedian says a
joke
it's all good they obviously have issues
behind the scenes and also if my husband
is going to go attack a guy
punch him like come on a [ __ ]
exactly so the [ __ ] laughed that's
that's
it was a [ __ ] move is what you're
saying he's so feminine will what you
got on this situation yeah we talked
about it earlier right but we talked
about the reiterate how feminine the
slap was imagine if he actually punched
him though that would be like extremely
that we're gonna do it that would have
went even more
yeah so you're basically saying if he's
going to do it dude
leave the [ __ ] at home exactly stick
that guy in the face you know he
offended your wife if you're going to do
it yeah if you're going to do i don't
think you should have done it yeah if
you're going to do it be a man about it
it shows the
relationship between the two who wears
the pants in the relationship so are you
thinking are you saying that she wears
the pants
uh yeah that's what you're saying she
wears the pants yeah why uh i would say
given i mean at the red table they had
to talk about her cheating on
that i think that definitely comes in
the scene for sure yeah it's like a
build up and i think it was almost like
the
will and they're really i mean i don't
know the relationship but yeah it's
obviously not strong so
little i think their relationship um is
very like very into the public eye
and like they have to deal with that
stuff when they're at home so i think
that plays a lot into like you know
they're at the oscars and this stuff is
happening to them and they're like oh
like our relationship is already in the
public eye like how can i make myself
seem like
masculine more like a man and it's
showbiz it's hollywood
[Music]